you know recently I was in Florida
Orlando Florida hanging out with a few
friends and it was late at night I was
having conversation with one of the
friends of ours out there who is trying
to build her business and she got pretty
emotional and we kept continuing to have
a conversation together about life in
that you could tell the belief in her on
what was said by a mentor of hers in the
past that she will never do anything big
in her life and that has had an
influence in her life
15 years can you imagine that and I
think about sometime when I'm driving
home and I'm stuck in traffic say on a
freeway and I look at the person next to
me and I say what is the person dreaming
about is the person still fighting for
their dreams have they given up on their
dreams I mean so many people across the
country that are simply they lack belief
in themselves and they are now living
somebody else's life they are very
vicariously living through you know
America's Got Talent
or you know you got these different
people on TV shows or athletes or
Hollywood actors they're living through
so many different people and they've
given up on themselves and you know why
it is because someone in their life
one or two people lied to them and they
bought the lies and those lies have
completely gotten them to play defense
am i shut down they've given up they
could be 22 years old 28 years old 37
years old 36 years or 42 years a white
black Hispanic Asian educated uneducated
they have completely given up in life
because somebody sold them their bag of
lies that they're not good enough
they're not smart enough they're not
fast enough they're not intelligent
enough they've made a lot of mistakes in
the past and they keep reminding them
about the mistakes they made in the past
and they keep reliving these mistakes
them in the past and it's unfortunate
because I sit down and I'm having
conversations with different people
every time it takes me 5 10 15 20
to hear a story of a person you know one
of the ladies told me about her story of
how she came here from Jamaica and how
she became an entrepreneur and she
brought her son here and she wanted to
become a citizen in America so she got a
four-year degree she worked so hard she
came out here and she sacrificed
everything why her son was back in
Jamaica and then flew her son out here
in Iran and to us and he when he got a
degree in he's now on his own he's about
to become a pharmacist in these stories
inspire me somebody told her she
couldn't do it and she overcame it but
how many people by the lies and give up
so many of them and it bothers me really
bothers me it upsets me it irritates me
because it lets me know how strong our
words are and I know none of us are
perfect and I know many of us have
probably said something hurtful to
somebody that bothers us and we feel
guilty for it and on the other end we
have people that have told us things
that have been hurtful and we've been
holding on to it for too long the time
and it stops us from going out there and
living our life but the truth is this
here's the truth and the truth is every
I mean I'm telling you right now the
truth is you are so special of a human
being that we forget how many things
we've overcome in our lives how many
challenges we've overcome in life and
you go back to your story and you think
about it you have so many special
moments of what you've done
so many of them of what you've been
you're so capable of doing so many great
things in life and you got to stop
buying those lives you know what those
comments are normally somebody that was
very close to you could be a father a
mother or brother or sister or
girlfriend an ex-wife and ex-husband or
a coach a teacher somebody and uncle
somebody really respected and they said
something too hurtful one day and you've
been hanging on to it you got to let it
go because the truth of the matter is
the people that do big things in life
they eventually realize how special they
are
and they're no more different than you
are I'm telling you right now they are
not much different than you are they
just finally realize how special they
are and they're using their god-given
gifts to go out there and do great
things so you know I had this on my mind
today and I just wanted to share my
feelings my dots with you I know it's
unusual because it's not the typical
value taemin episodes but I just felt it
on my heart to share that with you today
thank you for listening to my thoughts